what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we got a new look at moon knight
not only do we have a new trailer
showing us some awesome new footage for
moon knight and the cast and crew
talking a little bit about it but we
also do have an article by usa today
that gives us a lot of information that
we didn't really know before about the
upcoming disney plus show and some new
posters have been revealed as well which
are totally awesome and i said it before
and i'll say it again i think this is
definitely going to be one of my
favorite marvel studios disney plush
shows we have a lot to break down today
so let's dive into it and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news so for those who might not
have seen the trailer yet let's go ahead
and watch it
[Music]
the fun of moon knight is getting
introduced to a new superhero in a new
world
it's a real legitimate character study
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life
and dreams
moon knight is a spectacular character's
got an incredibly unique visual look
our job was to kind of put a lens on the
things that had the most uh dramatic
juice and ultimately take the mental
health aspect incredibly seriously
i am
stephen
the way we're tackling the story we
learn about stephen and then learn about
mark what's wrong with you mark
why did you call me mark and they're the
same person
[Music]
the tone is like fight club meets
indiana jones it's a bit dark at times
to tie it into something so vast and
supernatural it's amazing
thank you
every aspect of this show has a duality
and we've shifted the paradigm
for me what's really exciting is that
it's totally unpredictable
[Music]
now if you're new to moon knight and you
don't really know that much about him
you could probably tell from the trailer
that he has multiple personalities he
suffers from dissociative identity
disorder so when he goes from one
character to another the character that
he becomes cannot remember anything that
the previous character did also at the
same time he is enslaved by the egyptian
god konchu and in this article by usa
today oscar isaac actually gives us a
lot of information about his alternate
personalities and actually quite a bit
of details about the plot of moon knight
so let's go ahead and break that down
the article starts off by saying the new
six episode disney plus series
introduces isaac as a supernatural
vigilante and two-fisted avatar of the
egyptian deity khonshu with several
other sides surfacing due to
dissociative identity disorder there's
american mercenary mark spectre
why did you call me mark british gift
shop employee stephen grant caped
crusader moon knight and the mysterious
suitclad mr knight and usa today goes on
to say that and those are just the
personalities we can mention before the
show starts meaning there are actually
going to be several more personalities
that we see mark spector have in the
comics mark spector is kind of the
original person that is moon knight and
even in this interview one of the
executive producers grant curtis says
that this is the journey of mark spector
he says it's a story about identity and
finding one's true self the journey that
mark spector is on during our whole show
is who am i and how do i reconcile
portions of my past present and
potential future that i don't
necessarily agree with coming to terms
with our baggage and learning to live
with ourselves is what we all deal with
on a day-to-day basis so although this
is indeed going to be a very
supernatural show dealing with egyptian
gods and such which we're about to talk
about but it's also going to be kind of
realistic in the fact that they're going
to address very realistic things like
mental health while at the same time
this is going to be a kind of dark show
and apparently he's going to be meeting
some other worldly beings now we know
he's going to be meeting konchu but
perhaps there's going to be more the
article says steven suffers from random
blackouts voices in his head and trouble
distinguishing between his waking and
dream lives with flashing visions of
egyptian relics and memories that aren't
his own he stumbles into some dangerous
otherworldly dealings and meets mark
creating an initial tension between the
two personalities with different goals
and objectives so in this trailer and in
the very first trailer that we got for
moon knight we see who is actually
stephen pick up the phone and somebody
addresses him by the name mark and he
says why did you call me mark now again
mark is the original who comes in
contact with konchu the egyptian god and
since he says that he has flashbacks of
egyptian relics and voices in his head
i'm assuming those are the memories and
flashbacks of mark or they actually
could be the memories of the egyptian
god khan shu because konchu uses mark as
his avatar in this world and we'll get
to that story in just a bit but oscar
isaac actually describes the differences
between stephen grant and mark spector
here in this article he says viewers
first meet stephen an english bloke who
is a bit confused and doesn't have great
social skills and says the wrong things
at the wrong times and is completely
sincere he's also someone longing for a
connection and in a way could be the
counterpoint to the classic tortured
dark vigilante guy we've seen a lot but
then he says with mark spector i leaned
into this chicago guy who pushes people
away you feel the way steven feels why
is he such a jerk i don't really want to
be around him as the story progresses
you see that happen so not only is mark
spector steven grant all of the
different identities going to have all
of the different identities but they're
not going to get along with each other
in fact oscar isaac said that it was
important that the series feels
experimental for audience members and
quite true to the psychological horror
of not knowing what's happening and the
slow revelations of the truth and we can
definitely see that in some parts of
this trailer with the god konshu now
there are actually several new scenes of
khanshu in this trailer and each scene
with konshu is pretty intense and kind
of scary it looks like mark slash steven
slash whoever he is at the time is
always running away from him and kanchi
was always kind of chasing him so big
horror vibes there but what i think
they're going to be exploring is whether
or not mark spector can actually tell if
konchu is real or fake in the comics
even moon knight himself doubts it
sometimes he doesn't really know and no
one else really believes him as well
they just think he's crazy originally
mark spector was a mercenary he was a
former marine and he was former cia but
as a mercenary he took a job in sudan
where a fellow mercenary bushman killed
an archaeologist
mark was appalled at this behavior and
he actually saved the archaeologist's
daughter marlene who we believe is
actually going to be the character leila
in the show marlene would eventually go
on to become his lover and the mother of
his daughter but mark stood up to
bushmen in which bushman practically
killed him he fatally wounded him and
mark crawled away he crawls away to a
tomb and he actually dies but he dies in
front of a statue of the egyptian moon
god konchu he dies but he is suddenly
then revived and fully healed and he
claims that konchu wants him to be his
moon knight and he wants him to redeem
his life of violence and protect and
avenge the innocent now for a long time
it's not known if kanchu is actually
real or is simply made up by mark
spector in his mind but eventually it is
revealed that konchu is indeed real and
he's one of several entities from a
place called the other void a dimension
outside of normal time and space and
these people were worshiped as gods by
ancient earth people so if they stay
true to this fact in the comics the
consu that we see here is indeed real
and we actually see one particular scene
towards the end of this trailer where it
looks like konchi was doing something
pretty big perhaps showing mark the
world where he comes from or perhaps
this is some type of an attack some type
of a defense or perhaps just a vision
but what looks like is happening here in
this trailer in the first trailer is
that steven grant and the other
personalities have kind of repressed the
mark spectre personality because mark
specter is the one who is originally
contacted and resurrected essentially by
konchu and that's why steven grant has
all of these memories of ancient egypt
egyptian relics but he doesn't know
where they're from because it's mark's
memories and they've repressed them and
as far as ethan hawke's villain goes we
don't really know that much about him
yet but it does look like he's leading
somewhat of a cult so i'm assuming that
he is searching for the ancient god
konchu as well and realizes that mark
spector might actually be the avatar for
konchu which is why we can see oscar
isaac in egypt at some points in this
trailer and a lot of people are actually
surrounding him and it does look like
he's kind of there against his will and
could be a prisoner this could be ethan
huck's villain and their cult kidnapping
him taking him to konchu's statue and
perhaps trying to offer him as some sort
of a sacrifice to the god whatever it
may be this trailer looks fantastic and
the story of moon knight is apparently
going to be pretty epic a dark
supernatural show that is going to focus
on mental illness it's going to be
pretty great but let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on
future mcu videos for live updates you
can follow me on instagram or twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof